[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 dossiers une
émission consacrée ce mois ci au 50e
anniversaire de mai 68
mais
il
là
blocages d'universités occupations
d'entreprises grève des yvelinois ont
participé aux événements de mai 68
d'autres soutenu la politique menée par
le général de gaulle comme le président
du sénat gérard larcher que vous
entendrez lors de cette édition
mais pour commencer nous sommes allés à
votre rencontre pour connaître le regard
que vous portez sur mai 68
regardez on a encore les mêmes les
mouvements étudiants aujourd'hui
notamment dans les bois avec et blocus
et pour moi c'est quelque chose quelque
chose finalement qui n'est pas en temps
pour elle et qui persiste encore les
étudiants se sont révoltés un peu et ça
fait beaucoup de dégâts quand même
c'était un changement qui a été créé
des modifications dans les rapports
sociaux dans la morale publique et dans
la politique
avant de retrouver gérard larcher nous
vous proposons deux témoignages
d'illinois ils ont participé aux
mobilisations de mai et juin 1968 pierre
des gens étaient étudiants j'en perds
wolf lui travaillait à l'usiné renault
de billancourt découverte de leurs
souvenirs avec camille lambert l'a bien
entendu c'est l'inévitable réunion de
des étudiants comité d'action une
réunion à laquelle a participé pierre
dejean en mai 1968 cet habitant de
montigny le bretonneux à 19 ans il est
étudiant en génie électrique à l'iut de
ville d'avray
les affrontements entre étudiants et
policiers le 10 mai 1968 ont déclenché
la mobilisation dans cet établissement
le gouvernement à cette époque là d'un
le le 10 mai a fait un acte d'autorité
qui n'était pas justifié et on a fait le
tour des classes qui était déjà donc
entamé plus on a dit écoutez il ya quand
même eu des événements importants
cette nuit une répression à c'est assez
dur faut au moins que pour fasse quelque
chose on fait on fait une manifestation
à ville d'avray la mobilisation ne
s'arrête pas là
des professeurs de l'iut se joignent au
mouvement les cours sont arrêtés
la grève est lancé malgré l'opposition
de certains étudiants
on est libre écoute on fait pas grève on
suspend les cours ce qui est exactement
la même chose mais pour d'autres qu'il
voulait pas s'engager pas ça permet
effectivement da tout arrêter des photos
des journaux ou des caricatures pierre
dejean conserve de nombreux souvenirs
des mobilisations sociales notamment la
manifestation du 13 mai 1968 à paris un
des slogans comme bug qui est scandée
moment cette même station ses 10 ans ça
suffit
10 ans ça suffit
la société effectivement très bloqués on
palais fallait que ça change quoi
fallait que ça change
le changement c'était aussi la
principale revendication des ouvriers de
l'usiné renault à billancourt
jean pierre wolf avait 30 ans à l'époque
il vivait à versailles et travailler sur
l'outillage il produisait des machines
pour fabriquer des voitures sur l'île
seguin
la mobilisation a commencé le 16 mai à
boulogne on a des idées
d'arrêter le travail et que les
étudiants soient onu bon nous dire
comment voulez faire c'est là où leur a
dit oh je vois gelin vous êtes chez vous
on est chez nous des revendications
distincte des étudiants comme
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
la hausse des salaires ou encore plus de
protection sociale l'augmentation
générale des salaires pour toutes les
catégories et cet album c'était le
secrétaire du syndicat jean pierre wolf
se souvient du mouvement l'intérieur de
l'usiné
tout comme le travail sur les machines
la mobilisation s'est faite avec son
binôme
on a mis nos machines en état de de
propreté de conservation du mollet
depuis ce qu'on allait permettre le
boulot tout de suite
donc on les a nettoyés comme il fallait
qu'il soit et puis on les a évidemment
on les a et 1 et puis on a commencé à
occuper l'usiné entre en août 33 34
jaune me rappelle plus combien de temps
tu as bien on a dormi là bas une nuit
tron le 17 juin 1968 la reprise du
travail est votée
jean pierre wolf et ses confrères ont
obtenu notamment une hausse de leurs
salaires
nous poursuivons ce 7,8 dossier consacré
aux 50 ans de mai 68 avec le président
du sénat et sénateur les républicains
des yvelines gérard larcher bonjour
bonjour alors je rappelle que vous êtes
le deuxième personnage de l'état et que
vous êtes un gaulliste assumer au mois
de mai 1968 vous aviez dix neuf ans il
vous étiez engagé depuis 1966 chez les
jeunes gaullistes au moment de ces
mobilisations étudiants qui ont éclaté
en 1968 comment vous percevez ces
événements d'abord je suis engagé c'est
vrai chez les jeunes gaullistes et ma
première réaction c'est dire mais qu'est
ce qu'ils veulent ces gauchistes
en même temps je perçois qui a là un
mouvement de société et en même temps
c'est le reflet de très nombreux jeunes
engagés engagé politiquement engagé
syndicalement engagé aussi dans la vie
des aumôneries au spirituel et cette
réalité là fait que nous sommes assez
nombreux et j'allais dire à avoir une
appartenance politique
en tous les cas des références
politiques j'ai le souvenir de copains
plutôt à gauche d'autres plutôt à droite
de centristes et cet engagement s'est
pas uniquement un ou deux dans une
classe de 1ère ou dans une classe de
terminale et donc pour moi je vis 68
engagé comme jeune gaulliste et comme je
ne lis qui entend soutenir l'action du
général de gaulle mais qui en même temps
mesure que cet engagement est aussi le
questionnement le questionnement de la
société de 68 après une période
extraordinaire chat lisière de
croissance nous n'avions aucun problème
pour trouver un emploi à la sortie de
nos études et quand vous voyez que
le gouvernement ordonne peut-être une
répression sur ces jeunes qui
manifestent qui ont quasiment votre âge
quelle réaction vous avez d'abord les
jeunes et ils ont pas j'allais dire à
moitié moi j'ai des souvenirs très
précis puisque je suis en classe
préparatoire vétérinaire voilà que des
jeunes veulent m'empêcher de passer le
concours vétérinaire et je vous cache
pas j'ai pas fait le coup de poing mais
quand même pas loin en même temps
j'étais engagé puisque je représentais
les classes préparatoires au conseil
d'administration riez je n'étais pas
passifs et le jeune engagé que je suis
décide qu on à l'europe passer ses
examens décide d'aller dialoguer
dialoguer c'est un mot atténuée après
cinq décennies d'aller débattre avec un
certain nombre de ces jeunes
en même temps nous assistons à la
paralysie progressive du pays parce que
il ya toute la dimension salé ans social
et cette dimension sociale en même temps
la répression
mai 68 il n'y a pas un seul mort à
méditer sur la manière dont d'ailleurs
le pouvoir a conduit alors qu'il y avait
des manifestations et une manifestation
et 2 millions de manifestants
jal et envir justement parce que vous
parlez du mouvement social derrière
c'est les ouvriers qui qui vont
manifester vers le 13 mai il commence à
dessiner des à montrer leurs
revendications salariales notamment
quel regard vous portiez à c'est à ce
moment là sur la politique notamment
économique menée par le gouvernement
remplit d'où nous sommes dans le plein
emploi mais il ya désir de modernisation
je crois des relations sociales
il ya un désir de mieux partager les
fruits du développement et on sent une
société qui veut évoluer évolué
notamment ça passe par les accords de
grenelle 6027 est alors après il ya un
épisode cour remarque souvent de mai 68
c'est un tournant c'est le 30 mai qu'est
ce qui se passe dans votre esprit de
jeunes gaullistes
quand vous
ayez que le général de gaulle quitte la
france on ne sait pas où il va à ce
moment là c'est seulement après qu'on
saura qu'il étale et en allemagne à
baden baden qu'est ce qui se passe est
ce que vous êtes dit à un moment donné
vous avez douté du général de gaulle à
ce moment là d'abord grenelle les
accords sociaux
c'est sans doute là que je puise ma
passion pour le dialogue social et cette
passion pour le dialogue social
elle s'inscrit dans mon engagement des
mes 18 ans et elle va ensuite être
confortée par toute la vie d'engagement
politique que j'ai autour des hôpitaux à
proximité avec philippe seguin mais
grenelle c'est quand même la voie du
dialogue social pour sortir d'une crise
mais il ne suffit pas des accords de
grenelle on le voit bien 24 je crois le
général de gaulle prononça premier
discours se passe rien il ya des accords
et en même temps il ya cette
extraordinaire mouvement qu'on va
retrouver 30 mai moi j'ai jamais douté
du général mais est ce que je me suis
posé des questions à ce moment là non
mais naturellement je n'étais pas à
paris mais j'ai fait partie de l'immense
cohorte de ceux qui ont soutenu le
général de gaulle merci gérard larcher
de nous avoir accueillis ici sur nos
terres de rambouillet dans ma maison en
juillet et dans ma permanence où je
continue à recevoir les citoyens et
maintenant je vous propose justement un
regard croisé sur mai 68 et le lien qui
peut être fait avec ce qui se passe
actuellement au niveau des mobilisations
sociales d'un côté un représentant
syndical de l'unef de l'université
versailles saint quentin de l'autre un
universitaire spécialiste de l'histoire
contemporaine
regardez
[Musique]
pour l'université ça a permis une
période de libéralisation on a décidé de
changer un peu des méthodes archaïques
qui étaient en cours à l'université sur
l'érection des libération des moeurs
aussi ça a permis d'enclencher ce qu'on
a appelé la révolution sexuelle aussi
sur la question sociale
mai 68 c'est des acquis sociaux
augmentation des salaires améliorons des
conditions de travail
donc même si ça reste loin en mai 68
c'est quand même pas mal d'acquis et qui
ne juge pas encore aujourd'hui en fait
je pense qu'il faut prendre en compte
une séquence plus longue qu'on appelle
désormais les années 68 qui prennent
racine dans les années 60 qui s'étend
jusque dans les années 70
et là c'est vraiment un moment charnière
dans l'histoire française avec
d'intenses transformations politiques
sociales et culturelles
[Musique]
je pense c'est un peu des deux on
recommence beaucoup mai 68 est
extrêmement renoncé il ya un peu un
mythe révolutionnaire au tour
régulièrement dit voilà enfermé 68 c'est
pas mal ce qui est en cours actuellement
nos gars beaucoup du mythe c'est sûr on
pense beaucoup ils sont aussi une
réalité et ça a été un fort mouvement et
si c'est justement si on en parle comme
un mythe c'est parce qu'il a marqué des
générations et des générations et que
l'on tente même si le contexte est
différent de recréer un mouvement
d'ampleur équivalente alors c'est vrai
que mai 68 avec une majuscule dans
lequel on oublie le mois de juin et puis
cette séquence plus lente de
contestation est devenue un mythe
au fil des années des contestations des
discours un peu stéréotypé sûr sur cette
époque
néanmoins on a quelque chose qui est
quand même assez extraordinaire dans
l'histoire ne serait ce que par
l'ampleur de la contestation dans
évidemment les universités mais aussi
dans le monde du travail
[Musique]
l'idée ce n'est pas de refaire un mai 68
puisque l'idée c'est pas refaire les
mêmes choses par le passé par contre oui
clairement aujourd'hui comme en mai 68
on se rend compte que étudiants salariés
ont soit un stand attaque nous c'est la
mise en place de la sélection à l'entrée
de l'université c'est la fin de nos
droits comme le rattrapage à la
compensation et nous ce qu'on veut c'est
la faire converger les luttes qui est le
plus de médiation possible et qu'on
arrive à faire plier ce gouvernement
alors évidemment il ya des effets de
résonance parce que parcours sup c'est
une mobilisation qui contestent la
sélection à l'université que c'était
déjà à l'ordre du jour de la réforme de
l'université en 68 et c'était déjà
contesté à ce moment là donc
effectivement il ya des effets de
résonance mais aussi ce qu'on retrouve
comme élément de comparaison c'est que
on a des mobilisations qui se font dans
différents milieux sociaux
[Musique]